It just seems unfathomable that an entire app that's used by a hundred
million users across America,
and that's only America not across the entire world would have the possibility
of being banned. That's insane. However,
my mom sends me so many news articles and I read about it
so much and people just like the news. Y'all the news. They just be saying like,
it's coming tomorrow.
We're looking at TechTalk. We may be banning tech docs in less than one year.
We have almost 35 million followers on Tik TOK.
It's one of the most popular social media apps out there.
[inaudible] hi everyone. My name is Betsy. See my ad. Is that just that fee?
And I'm a comedian slash Mike yeller.
Hello. My name is Sean Sitara, Donna from Shonda's magic and I make combi.
Hey, I'm Allen chicken chow. My ad is Alan chicken chow and I make comedies.
Hello. My name is Hilda.
My aunt has put Tilda tomorrow and I'm all about self love,
baby and storytelling. Hi, my name's Ashley.
My username is pithy and Festus and I frequent which talk and a cult talk.
I utilize my great Danes. I'm a bathroom.
I am nervous about a potential Tik TOK ban,
The first take top gear ban or whatever I want to alive or whatever.
I was like, I was crying so much
on my Instagram. I was,
I was a wallet and it was so embarrassing.
My friends looked like screenshots of me crying and stuff like that.
It was so bad. But at that point in time is when I was like burst growing fast.
Like I was growing fast and I was like, kind of nervous. Cause like,
I'll put in all this hard work just for it to be taken away. Yeah.
My first reaction to I like took the tech talk and I like, it was almost,
I put my bootstraps on and I was like, they can not take us down. You guys,
they will not touch us. I went in for a second and I don't know.
What I kind of realize is with our brands,
especially people who have developed an emotional connection with us enough that
they'll find us afterwards. Also, where were these thoughts, words,
ideas come from. They can't just die.
Me. Uh, first and foremost, I honestly have a lot of faith and Tik TOK.
I think that they're actively working hard. I mean,
they're not going to just let go of this gigantic app. You know,
if tick-tock goes away today, like,
I feel like I feel confident in not just myself, but like all of us,
we're going to find a platform somewhere else and we're going to thrive in that
platform. So that's why I don't,
I don't really feel like any nervousness or pressure.
My professional answer is that I completely agree with that.
I think conceptually, like there is no basis for this band to go through Tik.
TOK is like a huge, huge tech company.
It just seems unfathomable that an entire app that's used by a hundred
million users across America and that's only America not across the entire world
would have the possibility of being banned. That's insane.
However,
my mom sends me so many news articles and I read about it
so much and people just like the news. Y'all the news. They just be saying like,
it's coming tomorrow. And I'm like, Oh my God,
like my apartment is going to be gone at this. Like, no.
I spent seven years in the air force.
And a big thing that we all have to do is we have like requirements for security
and stuff like that.
The big tell for me is that tick-tock is banned on government devices,
not personal devices for the military members.
So it was really that big of a security risk.
They would have had a bad audit for personal use as well.
We have things that are blacklisted every day when they have actual evidence
behind them. And if they're not banned,
if we're still making tick talks on deployment,
we're still doing it here and there.
I don't see where the substantial evidences anyone can get tech talk
famous.
I feel like it's easy to go viral, but to like maintain a fan base,
they got a really mash up energy. They gotta put you if they're not,
then you're just not fun to keep getting used.
Like it's just not going to happen. I think that it was a lot easier when we,
before the algorithm change one, they look for the first three seconds movement.
And if you don't move, you're not going to get on FYP page.
Your lighting is incredibly important as well as like being able to
engage your audience.
So the way that the Ted talk algorithm decides whether or not your video will
continue to get used, it's only through rewatch now. Not through likes,
not through comments and not through.
I also feel like it's kind of relative. Um,
I feel like in terms of like Tik TOK thing, cause like,
no one's tried to touch on like Charlie familiar, like the upper, like 1%,
like I think like, you know what I mean?
Like a couple hundred thousand people that like really rock with you, um,
is manageable. And I also feel like it, like, I completely agree with you.
Like it is a thousand percent about authenticity, but because of that,
anyone literally anyone can get to talk famous. If you have like a niche,
if there's something you're passionate about, Tik TOK has an audience for it.
And I feel like that's, what's different compared to any other platform.
If you compare to YouTube, it's so hard to grow on YouTube.
So you even Instagram, like there's not very much organic growth, but I mean,
like take talk, you post one video, you could get a hundred thousand followers.
My attractiveness plays a role.
And my success,
the years I spent,
I'm going to be someone I wasn't on Instagram and doing my makeup up and all of
those things, it wasn't until I said like,
so I took off the makeup now I just don't.
Give up. Like, and that those were the videos at first started popping up.
It is a component that can help creators. I mean, there are, you know,
girls and guys who, you know,
they're shopping literally just stand in front of a camera and can get millions
of views. Um, not my case,
but if I didn't have my personality nor nor my own,
like my own talent, I wouldn't be in the position I am today.
I think it does help. Like if, if your intention is to be like a trapper,
which by the way is like a very viable option for many people. And like,
you can have success. I mean, even outside of tech talk,
like there are celebrities like actors and singers who literally sell
that. That is like all they are. So it is a big selling point. If you,
if you want to go that.
I think looking different, uh, takes a big role on it.
Cause like, I look pretty mobile right now, but I had like green hair.
Then I had pink and I had blue and red and all types of colors and that kind of
drew attention towards me, like matching your hair with your eyebrows.
And like you get more compliments,
which gets people to see your videos and like start liking you.
Cause you're different.
So I think if you don't look like other people or you have your own type of
style to yourself, that's different. That definitely plays a role too.
I totally agree with you. I think that there's been like a big movement.
If you look different, like there's, mid-size tech talk,
which is what I'm a part of. I am not average size. I'm not plus size,
but people being able to see my very small five foot compact
body is what they like to see because it reminds them of like,
everyone is different.
That does add to your attraction is like, you know,
how to your personality attraction, isn't all looks.
I think attraction is kind of like the whole package and, and yeah,
it definitely like
what attracts you to somebody like it could be anything they could smell nice.
And it would be an attractive thing. I can fully support myself with money.
I make off tech talk.
I personally don't make a lot of money through the app, but I do.
I am able to funnel customers and clients through tech talk,
but I don't make money through tech talk, the creator fund for me. Um,
I've only made like $20 off of it.
So all of my support does not come from the internet.
I actually have two regular jobs as well.
Wow. I'm nowhere close to supporting myself fully off and pick doc. Um, I,
I, I made a couple of bucks off of that talk creator fund,
but then my views also started to dip and I don't know if that was,
I'm just like tuning it or whatnot,
or if it's because like now we're paying any preview,
your content has to be like top tier.
I think you could ultimately end up supporting yourself through other avenues,
like starting your own business.
Like dedicated myself to doing that.
Then I could make it happen some way shape or form,
but I'm like really helping people at the capacity that I am right now.
Then I'm, I'm.
Personally emotionally.
Like I'm thriving. I live with my sister, so I don't pay rent.
So I don't have to worry about rent, but like if I do have a job,
I work at target, but if I didn't work there,
I felt like I could like get the stuff that I need and stuff like that.
Cause I do like get brand deals and stuff like that.
Like this wig is a promotion. Video is free.
I don't have that many things that I need though. Like I'm not living by myself.
I don't pay for my car. So it's like in my lifestyle,
what I do need, I could.
Like make the leap of quitting my full-time job going without money for like
three months in order to be able to actually now like literally now
be able to like, like, um, to sustain myself.
It's definitely crazy to be able to do it. Um, but yeah,
I'm grateful for the, for, you know, the, the freedom.
I'm in like a really interesting boat because I started to talk last year and I
was, um, you know, a junior in high school. So I just graduated this year, um,
a high school. So I've actually never had like a quote unquote real job, um,
besides, you know, like social media or whatever, anything. Um,
but it wasn't until, you know, this year that I actually started to, you know,
make money and, um, it was, you know, through the live streams,
through brand deals, through, um, branded opportunities. Um, and you know,
now I'm able to, you know, I moved out and I have my own place now and uh,
all all through Tik TOK. So I'm very blessed. I'm very grateful for everything.
Tuck community feels safe.
Who's accidentally ended up on a porn site.
I've had like multiple videos that have been taken off of multiple social media
platforms that people then go and upload to PornHub or X videos
I'm fully clothed.
I don't really ever do things in like a sports bar or a bikini or whatever.
It's just not my thing, but yeah. How did you find them? Um,
I had a follower of mine who
messaged it to me and they're like, Hey, um, you know, you're on porn up.
And I was like, I am. And they're like, yeah,
you've got like a a hundred percent rating right now. And I was like, wow,
where's my cut. Like where's my money. Come on. So,
um, yeah, I accidentally became a porn star.
Or you page it's very particular to you, you know,
you're rarely going to find a video that you strongly disagree with with that,
the comments and all of the, you know,
kind of the community and the vibe going around is like, you know,
it's going to be relatively the same as yours. Um, and I compare that to like,
when I G uh, sorry,
Instagram released IgE reels when they released reels,
like I was looking through the comments and they're just way harsh or then
there's so much like just compared to, um, to Tik TOK.
So, um, in that, in that respect, um, yeah, I feel like it is, you know,
somewhat, somewhat pretty safe. Um, there are definitely instances where,
you know, like we've,
we've seen like with a lot of drama and stuff where it can get really toxic and,
um, like, you know, not the best space for, uh, for users influencers and,
you know, just like the kids in general who consume this content.
But in general, I think, I think tick-tock has done a pretty,
pretty decent job on keeping a safe community.
I've experienced both a lot of negativity and a lot of positivity.
Somehow one of my videos, um,
ended up on straight tech talk and I got body shamed really hard.
And I was like, this is not what I'm used to. I also,
as a spiritual minority, I get a lot of hate.
I get a lot of clown emojis.
I get called a psychopath I've been called mentally ill. Um,
so I actually use common blockers now to make sure that that kind of stuff
doesn't, um, filter through,
especially because I work really hard to try to keep a safe space for people who
are curious about spirituality and they don't need to see people who,
who are gonna put you down for X self exploration.
I feel in competition with other creators.
I'm like a comedian, a Mike yeller. I do all this like funny stuff.
So there's so many people who do what I do. And it's like crazy.
And like a specific tech talker.
He wanted to like block me and call me out for stealing his content when I never
saw him in my entire life. And like,
we even talked about it and he still posted our stuff about me.
So I was just like, okay.
So I felt like at some point I was competing with him cause we were doing the
same thing and our followers were like picking sides, choosing. So like,
that's like the personal experience I had.
Spirituality is not a competition. So in that way,
I think my niche of Tik TOK, uh, it's a little bit less competitive,
but maybe not necessarily not dramatic.
The Wichita community has this awful reputation being called witch toxic because
there's a lot of infighting and it really hurts to
see people who try to attack each other over something like personal beliefs.
Uh, I think that that's really silly.
I also would like to say that not every person is going to like everybody and
that's okay. So if I have never act on the people that I disliked,
I simply block and move on.
I personally believe that, you know,
there's so much opportunity in this world for everybody. So like, um, you know,
just because someone else succeeds or is doing well doesn't mean, you know,
you can't either. So I don't ever see as like, you know, a competition it's,
you know, it's my own personal gain. And if someone else has done well,
all power to you, you know, a good job, that's all you.
And there's so much more opportunity for everybody else.
I think my content makes a difference in people's lives.
I get a lot of messages from like parents,
a little kids that just broke their back or just broke their neck.
Or they were born with CP and they're like going through their school years.
They didn't want to do, they didn't want to do.
That. And they stopped me driving my truck with hand controls and they're like,
mommy, I want to drive a truck like that. I thought I could only have a minivan.
I'm able to like show them a whole new world that a lot of people don't think
could even exist.
The fan pages I have, or like the DMS or like the, um,
comments on Tik TOK. They really do mean a lot. I just wanted to say,
I love you so much. You brighten my day.
Like hearing them physically say that is just something different.
Right? Seeing the things I've struggled with,
and maybe me not speaking directly on them,
but maybe the energy or just collectively the things I'm saying, adding up.
And then it translating with people.
One of the things I've kind of always dealt with in the last, like, you know,
throughout my journey and self-love and eating disorders and all of this stuff
is like looking in the mirror.
And that was always a really big thing for me that just in seeing a super
distorted version of myself, um,
and I got a video from a girl not too long ago and it was her speaking.
So like Duchess C said about really hearing it. That's so different.
This girl said that she stared in her.
She stared at herself in the mirror for 30 minutes and saw how beautiful she was
after watching my videos. It's perfect. I'm so happy with what I with.
I don't know if Tik TOK were to go tomorrow, whatever happens.
I'm so happy to be where I'm at and be doing what I'm doing.
I'm excited to go make a video after this.